let's talk
about the coup the military announcing a
state of emergency
myanmar's 10-year journey to democracy
appears to be
over myanmar is now run by a general
after the military deposed the
government led by aung sangsuji
in a bizarre fluke part of the coup was
even caught on video
while a fitness instructor did her
routine in front of parliament
the army's declared a state of emergency
for the next year they've arrested
politicians
and shut down social media
demonstrations are the largest
since the 2007 uprising against the
military
this is the myanmar military scrapping
the democratic experiment
we asked you to send us your questions
about what's going on in myanmar
so we got you some answers
let's start by getting everyone up to
speed with what's been happening in
myanmar
what used to be called burma essentially
this is about a rivalry
between the military and a popular
pro-democracy movement led by aung
sang-su chi
and her nld party
people in myanmar were put through
almost 50 years of military rule
the country was basically closed off to
the world and
international sanctions hurt
there were recurring protests and
violent military crackdowns while aung
tsuchi made a name for herself as the
face of the opposition
she spent a total of 15 years under
house arrest her efforts won her a nobel
peace prize
then came what people call myanmar's
experiment with democracy
there was a referendum attempts at free
elections
and foreign investment increased
in 2015 aung sang and her nld party
won in a landslide people now have
enjoyed
10 years of much greater freedom in
terms of
information media social media
communication civil society
organizations and
it's difficult to put that back in a
bottle which brings us to the coup
and your questions the first one is why
now
well the military says it had issues
with the parliamentary elections
in november the nld won in another
landslide
more than 80 of the vote but the
military disputed the results
saying there was fraud so was there any
proof of fraud
well no one saying the vote was perfect
for instance
in some of the conflict areas people
couldn't vote but
i think equally there can be no doubt
that the election results reflected the
will of
the people in the vast majority of the
country which brings us to how the
military got so powerful
it's because that power has come in
handy for maintaining control
myanmar borders india bangladesh china
laos
and thailand it's such a diverse country
it has more than 130 ethnic groups
and ethnic divisions only got worse
under japanese and british rule
and then burma got its independence the
burmese national flag was hoisted with
all due ceremony
power was unexpectedly handed to the
majority burmans
a deal that excluded numerous ethnic
minorities
in the first 10 to 15 years of
independence there were a series of
reasonable rebellions
the military believed it was the only
force that could take care of it to hold
the country together
and make sure that the ethnic berman
majority is
on top so the military has been in power
but at one point decides to share
control and create some kind of
democracy
so here's the next question why is the
military guaranteed 25
of the seats in parliament well it's
because in 2008 the military put it in
the new constitution
it also kept control of defense interior
ministries
and key positions in the cabinet but it
wasn't just political control
they got into business too the military
created two
huge conglomerates made up of local and
foreign companies
the military's economic holdings extends
right throughout the economy
in a sense the military is a kind of a
government within a government or
a government above a government because
the military has had that much influence
a lot of people saw aung sangsuji as a
puppet so this viewer asks
if that's the case what difference does
the ku make
well her power was limited that's true
su chi was disqualified from being
president because her children were born
abroad
that was also a clause written into the
2008 constitution
to get around that she created the role
of state counselor for herself
the military's got a hair trigger finger
and they were ready to take over at any
moment at the slightest sense that their
interests were not being met
and while she was in power aung tsuchi
didn't really criticize
the military something that was really
obvious when it came to the crackdown on
the rohingya
there are stateless muslim minority who
live in rakhine state
where the army says it's been carrying
out a counter-terrorism offensive
[Music]
but the un and others have described it
as a campaign of genocide
and crimes that include killing children
raping women
burning homes
basically using fear to push out more
than eight hundred thousand rohingya
into bangladesh
[Music]
and yet aung suchi defended the military
operation
genocidal intent cannot be the only
hypothesis
it's obviously cost her her status as an
icon of the international community and
human rights community
now tsuchi is back in detention so what
do the majority of people in myanmar
think about what's going on
well some seem to back the military also
known as the tatmada
there are nationalist groups inside the
country
who see you know the takador as a
defender of the nation
and in particular a defender of buddhism
but the fact is aung suchi is by far the
most popular
the people of myanmar were given the
chance to vote
in a free and fair election twice their
hero is aung san tsuchi
the party they want to rule is the nld
and they're protesting
[Applause]
these are some of the biggest crowds
since 2007
and they're spreading across the country
[Music]
some activists started what they call a
civil disobedience movement
honking horns banging pads
and giving a three-finger salute
[Music]
but the internet is being periodically
shut down and more and more people are
being arrested
this is a widening circle of uh not just
the political figures but writers
journalists
artists social media people human rights
defenders
okay so why go through all that trouble
why did the military stage this coup
now well the thing about myanmar's
military is it's closed and secretive
so we don't know for sure but the man
who gave the order is senior general
minong lang
one theory is that he and others were
worried about plans by the new
government
to bring in reforms like changing the
constitution
the nld had tried it before that failed
because of the military's 25
hold on parliament but it's thought to
have angered the military
but there's another theory and it's that
minong lang was acting in his own
self-interest
the current commander-in-chief is on the
verge of retirement
and this could very well be a desperate
move to salvage his own political career
and future
people shouldn't rush to assume that
everyone in the military is necessarily
happy about this
we will have a multi-party election and
will hand over power to the one who wins
in that election
so which world powers back the
military's decision
well countries like russia and china
have a close relationship with the
military
and both blocked a u.n resolution
condemning the coup
but pretty much everyone wants myanmar
to get back on track
i think there are no shortage of friends
no shortage of influences
the international community has to use
whatever techniques that it can to try
to encourage a return to some kind of
power sharing with the civilians
the military has said it'll be in power
for a year
but the right mix of incentives and
pressure could convince the generals to
turn things around
and reinstate some form of democracy
one thing going for myanmar is that
they've done it before
[Music]
things are moving in myanmar and that's
why al jazeera is staying right across
what's happening there
so check out our website aljozer.com
which has all the latest
and i'll see you next week